we Embrace stuff because we see some
problem that's ging to us and we want to
solve it right that's the progressive
Instinct and so we tear apart some rule
that seems Antiquated to us and we
notice that you know yeah we've
liberated ourselves in some way and then
20 years later 30 years later we
discovered holy crap we liberated
ourselves in this way and then we
constrained ourselves in some other way
and we have to do a net analysis and
that the Carnage is tremendous if you
did that if you did it one thing at a
time it would be bad enough right the
the needless losses of doing it that way
would be intolerable in my opinion but
when you do it on every we're we're
doing it this way now instead of
occasionally kind of moving up the
ladder or something we are
revolutionizing our
civilization Each decade which means you
don't get time to even figure out what
the consequences of the last change you
made are before you're somehow on to
some next Monumental
change
what does that tell you about the
evolutionary process of the forces that
have led us here on the negative side so
if the force is on the positive side and
the ideas of of Classical liberalism
let's say and the things that have been
good for the 250 the last 250 years if
those are pretty good but clearly
faltering what does it tell you about
the bad ideas that somehow got into the
system there are a couple of con
ceps maybe I'll step back one second
what we teach people even before the
academy went completely insane the set
of things that we would teach somebody
on the way to graduating from college
was um pretty arbitrary it was not the
set of things that you would really want
to have on board in order to live a a a
a life in which you were empowered to do
meaningful things it was just sort of
some set of things that people people
had taught in the past and seemed like
they were still useful are you saying
lesbian bad Mitten 2011 isn't the no I
mean even even really almost everything
you know we don't teach the right
geology frankly in order to understand
what kind of a planet you live on the
biology we teach is not focused on the
things that actually allow you to figure
out how to evaluate claims about a
medication or of food or we just we we
are teaching a an arbitrary curriculum
and it's now gotten and it's turned into
a toxic curriculum but arbitrary wasn't
very good and so one of the things that
I would do you think that was arbitrary
or do you think that was by Design I
mean when when all the liberal arts
colleges started teaching all of this
nonsense instead of teaching I don't
know say either better at stem subjects
or or financial literacy let's say which
nobody learned in high school and then
they get to college and then they don't
even teach it do is that is that
arbitrary or is that intentional the
last chapter clearly involves a whole
hell of a lot of sabotage and frankly
you know the folks who um invented
postmodernism were pretty
straightforward about the fact that they
were interested in sabotage so shouldn't
surprise us but I mean even before that
um we were dealing with a chaotic
collection of ideas that weren't to get
we we we left a lot of value on the
table for no good reason and and so one
thing I would
do is I would look at certain Concepts
that are just disproportionately
important you know I didn't learn about
chesterton's fence until I don't know 20
16 maybe even later right chesterton's
fence is an incredibly important
principle the precautionary principle is
incredibly important the relevance that
these things have to the battle between
and I don't even want to say battle the
tension between conservatism and
progressivism which is a natural tension
I think if you kill either of those
things off you end up in one disaster or
another so understanding that um just
because you don't know why some thing
that we do is there doesn't mean it's
actually pointless and you damn well
better keep track of what happens if you
decide some
like the rules of interaction between
the Sexes if you think oh that's just
you know that's it's prudishness it's
oppressive it's you know whatever Force
you want to attribute it to and we're
we're wiser than that we know we're you
know we're just primates and let's just
get over it and stop pretending sex is
something other than it is okay you know
there's not that there's no truth in
that there is some truth in it but when
you get rid of all those rules you
invite a whole lot lot of chaos that you
didn't anticipate and it is incumbent on
you at least to track the consequences
of the change and see how they match
with what you thought was going to
happen if we had done that right if we
were comparing the world of 2023 with
the world of
1960 we could say oh there are some
things that are quite a bit better then
there are a whole bunch of things that
are a whole lot worse and we could start
looking at cause and effect and say
actually we could get the best of both
of those worlds without paying the huge
price we do by you know drawing a line
here but is the problem is the inherent
problem with that is that that's just
not how humans organize or or actually
respond to things so for example you
could say like gay marriage to me was a
completely just obviously a completely
just Mission and that it was a quality
for people to live the way they wish
there probably should have been a
discussion around it while going okay
well what's going to come after this
then and now this radical trans thing
which has nothing to do with equality
and now is an assault on science and
biology and blah blah that there should
have you're basically asking for well
can there be like a postmortem on the
good things so we don't let in the bad
things but it's almost just not how
humans operate right we just look then
for the next thing and that I guess is
the problem you're right this is exactly
how we do things I get want to show I
get want to show no you're you're right
on target um but notice notice this we
Embrace stuff because we see some
problem that's ging to us and we want to
solve it right that's the progress Rive
Instinct and so we tear apart some rule
that seems Antiquated to us and we
notice that you know yeah we've
liberated ourselves in some way and then
20 years later 30 years later we
discover holy crap we liberated
ourselves in this way and then we
constrained ourselves in some other way
and we have to do a net analysis and
that the Carnage is tremendous if you
did that if you did it one thing at a
time it would be bad enough right the
the needless losses of doing it that way
would be intolerable in my op opinion
but when you do it on every we're doing
it this way now instead of occasionally
kind of moving up the ladder or
something we are revolutionizing our
civilization Each decade which means you
don't get time to even figure out what
the consequences of the last change you
made are before you're somehow on to
some next Monumental change there is no
I mean anybody who has gotten good at
let's say making a car
run knows you can't do this right if you
have a problem with a car it's not
running right you change one thing at a
time and you figure out which thing
causes it suddenly to run now you know
what the problem is you know what to do
if you say well you know the car doesn't
run it could be the starter it could be
the alternator it could be the battery
it could be the wiring harnesses and you
change them all and it still doesn't run
you don't know that you didn't change
the thing that was broken and introduce
another thing that wasn't working and
that it's now not running for a whole
new reason
right you can't do it that way so one of
the lessons here
is the Rebellion into conservatism is
largely right because we've done a lot
of foolish things and we've done it too
fast and too many of them but it cannot
be allowed to silence the progressive
Instinct because the way we got here is
through progressivism if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
stop screaming check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell